to respond to russia's
aggression
we need to be strong
to get peace
that is why we are building on efforts
to cut off the funding for putin's war
machine through sanctions and today
madam deputy speaker i can announce we
will go further than ever before by
hitting
over 360 more people complicit with
putin's regime
they range
from former president dmitry medvedev
and defence minister
sergey shah shoigu
putin's propagandist
miria
zakarova
this means after today we will have
designated over 1 000 individuals and
entities under our russian sanctions
regime
and we are using our new powers under
the economic crime act to maximize that
impact this
would not have been possible without the
extraordinary efforts of colleagues
across this parliament
to help get this legislation through the
house so quickly and it shows our
collective determination to lead by
example
in punishing the putin regime
in december
he's right that we're sanctioning a lot
of people but in actual fact the we name
the people who are sanctioned and it's
other people that then do the
sanctioning by not engaging with them on
a financial basis not buying or selling
properties and all the rest of it one of
the difficulties at the moment is that
it's phenomenally difficult to find out
on the foreign office um sanctions list
who is and isn't sanctioned so for
instance the members of the duma who i
gather it was announced last week were
sanctioned they're still not on the
foreign office website list as far as i
can see anyway
so i just wonder whether there's a way
of making this far more readily
available to the wider population
because we need to deal not just with
the people who have 20 million pound
houses that we've all heard of but the
people who've got 750 000 pound flats in
london bought with russian dirty money
the many relatives for instance of
abramovich and um his ex-partners each
one of those needs to be dealt with and
each one of those properties needs to be
seized
uh the honourable gentleman makes an
important point about ensuring that we
give
due publicity
to the uh people institutions and
entities that have been sanctioned i'll
ensure that the
suggestion that he has made
is listened to by the department
in december we brought our g7 partners
together in liverpool
to warn putin
that invading ukraine would have massive
consequences and indeed we have followed
through on that pledge we have worked
with our allies to cut off such sectors
of the russian economy by targeting its
defence companies its trade and
transport sector and kicking banks out
of the swift financial system
we have led the way in our financial
sanctions targeting 10 russian banks and
we have hit
over 300 billion pounds worth of russian
bank assets
all this amounts to the toughest
sanctions package of any country and we
will work with and encourage all our
allies to keep ratcheting up their
efforts
as well
we will continue
to provide lethal military aid
to ukraine we were the first european
country to send defensive weapons
and we have already donated over
3600 n-law anti-tank weapons and also
now supplying javelin missiles